at Kadesh key jicama not crystal Rix's
he almost half a century Caroll Spinney
was one of America's most famous
television personalities many would have
struggled to spot him in the street
well hi ed welcome to Sesame Street
you're just in time as Big Bird and
Oscar the Grouch he captivated millions
of American children every week since
the show's first episode in 1969 it's
aimed to educate as well as entertain
youngsters was an instant hit and many
have credited it with transforming the
genre I got wonderful letters from
children C D Big Bird you're my friend
please come and play with me how about
next Thursday that was a great beauty
[Music]
the show success or it being broadcast
across the globe
when plaudits for the way in which a
champion diversity and inclusion it was
an interracial cast they lived in
harmony race was not an issue it taught
us it set an example it taught us by
example while also specifically teaching
us with lessons wow did I just hear
right the first lady ate seeds
Wow I love seed it's been he's
incredible work ethic which saw him
still performing well into his 80s led
to recognition from his peers I just
feel that I'm one of the luckiest birds
in the world now I'm an old bird myself
and and as I'm 72 and I get to play a
six-year-old on television still Caroll
Spinney was one of the last of the
show's original cast members when he
hung up his big bird costume for the
final time last year but his talent
creativity and unmistakable voice will
be remembered by millions of children
and adults around the world for years to
come Kip Bradshaw sky news